I had a change of
feeling about them a couple of years ago
you know I
I do I didn't like participating in much
well then showing up on time at work
and uh you know but I have to say though
you know it's it you make a little bit
of money
and
it's extraordinary I had this thing
happen where I know this is probably
very typical you probably happened to
you a million times but it never
happened to me before where a woman came
up
and it's a very simple thing she said
that her her dad was Ill he was in the
hospital and that he's been a huge fan
of mine his whole life and we were about
the same age
and uh
um you know and and I asked her if I
know it just hit me heavy and I asked
her if she would
you know you're not supposed to hold up
the line I asked her if I if she wanted
to FaceTime him and so she did
and I won't tell you what he said
specifically but he said some very
intense stuff to me about his health and
about his welfare and
and uh a particular thing about
just this little insignificant
part that I played in uh
um Adventures in Babysitting I played
Thor wow at the end right
yeah like I helped them with their car
yeah and then I give girl my uh
my winged helmet you know right right
that I kind of pull out oh no she gives
her she's dressed as Thor and she gives
me her winged helmet sorry
and uh because she believes that I'm
Thor and I'm kind of actually in the
adventures of babysitting world am I am
Thor and so uh at least that's what I
believed
anyway so he he you know there was this
little story that he told me about that
and about
um how men
uh have trouble with their questioning
their integrity all through life you
know and how a lot of men
suffer from worthlessness even if they
never admit it
and you know women women do too
obviously
um but this particular story was about
man
and uh that for some reason
that hit him that I would come off of
full metal jacket and play that little
part in that movie and look completely
different and like he found that to be
truly inspiring
I mean
how that kind of thing happens is beyond
me but
um
so like that's I've never ever been in
that position you know I I sign
autographs all the time I don't
I don't shy away from that people want
pictures I do that I've done that my
whole career I learned from Gregory
Hines
um a very good lesson about that yeah so
I'll tell you what Greg taught me in a
minute but but it was um you know so
I've always I've never shot away from
that kind of stuff but I've never
because I do more
um television and films than I do
theater you know
um like in three quarters of my career
is all theater I mean it's all films and
television and in very few plays and um
so I don't get that kind of thing you
know I don't get to hear what people
think of these little parts that I
played